trading platform robin hood one of the
most highly anticipated ipos of the year
that's a big deal for the retail
investor
but it could also come with some big
risks last year
millions of investors traded on the
broker [ __ ] robin hood
they were part of a trend since 2020
individual investors bought billions of
dollars in equities
driven by the rise in no fee trading
apps with robin hood leading the way
robin hood when it came onto the scene
really upended the industry
we believe that the more people that
have access to the markets and can start
investing earlier
the better off our economy will be after
a year of dramatic growth
robin hood filed for its ipo on july
first
but the filing comes as the brokerage
faces a collision course with regulators
including a new securities and exchange
commission chairman over a controversial
practice that robin hood uses to
generate most of its revenue
here's how robinhood went from startup
to ipo
in less than a decade and why it's
facing so much turmoil as it gears up to
go public
[Music]
in the 90s brokerages like e-trade and
ameritrade
started offering online trading services
which helped open up the stock market to
retail investors
but it was expensive internet trade for
eight dollars
trading fees could add up to hundreds or
even thousands of dollars a year
that was one of the reason why we saw
relatively muted levels of individual
investors in the market
caitlin mccabe reports on robin hood and
retail investing for the wall street
journal
it was cost prohibitive to try to be
trading all the time with these fees
that was the case until 2015 when robin
hood released its trading app
from the very beginning our mission has
been to democratize the financial system
this is robin hood co-founder beijoubat
and for us
this isn't a headline it's not a gimmick
or a billboard ad it's the central
reason why we started the company
to attract new investors robin hood
offered features that made investing
more accessible
it was one of the earliest brokerages to
offer no fee trading
it was also a pioneer in fractional
share trading
so suddenly you could buy 10 of amazon
or 50
of amazon you could just buy basically a
slice of that stock and it just made it
much easier for investors to access the
market in that way
but price wasn't the only thing keeping
retail investors out of the market so it
was just really intimidating to try to
trade and to try to figure out
charts and to understand what was
happening in the market
robin hood also experimented with
features aimed at keeping people engaged
when users would log on to the app and
place their first trade
it used to rain confetti stock numbers
turn like slot machines
and some of its messages to investors
use emojis
and it was just a very inviting app it
was very fun they were just very
kind of on the forefront of trying to
invite that millennial crowd
into trading and i think it worked i
think that's part of the reason why
millennials liked the app robin hood's
user base grew quickly
which caught the attention of its
competition by 2019
major brokerages like charles schwab and
td ameritrade had adopted zero
commission trading as well
it was this recognition of kind of what
robin hood
had built and the market share that it
had amassed and that kind of
was the the genesis of this new trading
era that we see today
and then in early 2020 the kovid 19
pandemic
took hold of the world we are looking at
another day of extreme volatility stocks
opened
just moments ago with the dow down more
than 600 points
i think with the market volatility a lot
of people said i think this is a good
time for me to try to get into the
market
and that's where we've really seen this
explosion of activity from
individual investors ever since
according to its ipo filing
robinhood counted 18 million users with
funded accounts at the end of march 2021
and the brokerage's first quarter
revenue more than quadrupled to 522
million dollars
but as robin hood has grown so has
criticism
that some of the apps features the very
ones that help make it successful
could cause problems for inexperienced
investors
critics said that the app's interface
which made it fun and easy to use
actually gamified trading and put
inexperienced investors at risk
trading is a challenging business larry
tabb is a financial markets analyst
who has studied market structure for
over 25 years you're competing
not only with some of the largest
investors in the world but you're
trading
um with some of the guys with the
biggest computers and the fastest data
feeds and the most sophisticated
analytics
it's really difficult to continually
beat them day in and day out
over the past year robin hood has also
faced criticism over how it makes its
money
and how it previously communicated that
with investors
in december 2020 robin hood agreed to
pay 65 million dollars to settle claims
that it didn't sufficiently disclose its
business deals with high-speed
trading firms and then there was
gamestop outrage erupting in this wild
and expensive battle that's playing out
between wall street heavyweights
small investors and these popular stock
trading apps
in january 2021 robin hood came under
scrutiny
after it restricted users from buying
gamestop as the company's share price
surged
the trading blackout caused some
investors to lose out on potential gains
about 50 class action lawsuits
investigations by regulators
and multiple hearings with members of
congress followed
here's robin hood's ceo speaking with
the house committee on financial
services
despite the unprecedented market
conditions in january
at the end of the day what happened is
unacceptable to us
to our customers i'm sorry and i
apologize
during the hearings lawmakers
scrutinized robin hood's use of a
financial practice called payment for
order flow
which allows the brokerage to route
customer orders through high-speed
trading firms
according to robinhood's ipo filing the
company made around 81 percent of its
first quarter revenue from this practice
payment for order flow has raised red
flags with the sec's new chairman gary
gensler
this inherent conflict is there and
whether we can
address it enough through disclosure
or it sort of implicates the broader
market structure and i've asked staff to
think about that broader market
structure
gensler is reviewing payment for order
flow which could have implications for
the future of robinhood
and no fee trading in general this is
part and parcel of robinhood
how they make money so it'll be really
interesting to see if gensler
you know decides to be a one-man
wrecking crew and
and really radically re-shift how
the economics of the retail brokerage
business robin hood has faced other
regulatory issues as well
in june the brokerage agreed to pay
nearly 70 million dollars to resolve
allegations that it misled customers
approved ineligible traders for risky
strategies
and didn't supervise technology that
failed and locked millions out of
trading
according to its ipo filing robinhood
continues to face
a number of regulatory inquiries still
some industry veterans say robinhood
will survive the sec's review
even if regulations are imposed